I know what you're thinking you're
thinking that right now I'm on the set
of Westworld or JJ Abrams latest sci-fi
futuristic concoction but no I'm at the
toto toilet showroom in Tokyo joining me
right now is a huge fan of Japanese
toilets he's talked about them quite a
little - Jordan a Steve Jordan tell me
what is it about Toto Japanese toilets
that you love so much I love any toilet
bowl that washes your anus people wash
every other part of their body that is
that it's never as dirty with soap and
water but the anus they say don't worry
about it just use this paper I just
don't understand even while the rest of
the world washes the anus the United
States sits back and says no we're okay
because a little piece of paper does
just as good a job so now I ask you
you're a proud American are you
confident in the cleanliness of your
anus that's the most patriotic speech
I've heard any American give in a long
time
meet mr. Kuwahara you were height you
work here Ohio oh I already did just do
it again
oh look at that life my friend is only
interested what happened
Mayan cool until Kings Timnath oh it
sterilized it's oh I thought it was
maybe I I thought I was making a point
of some kind I thought it was for jump
you're welcome to speak anytime my
friend only wishes a toilet with washing
capability
I don't believe washing one's anus
should be a luxury I believe washed
anyone's anus is a right not a privilege
yeah
yeah John F Kennedy I think said you
know we much but you've taken that and
probably elevated it how does the stream
of water know how to hit its mark they
taking dick a night you need that's the
the average anus point but what if
someone was outside the average mine is
more here we don't know what happened
but it drifted it's here I'm sort of
like this
I think it's barbaric that we have to go
to the toilet
I think the toilet should come to us and
it comes and finds me when it's time and
it just not just me like a dog I'm like
what the hey he's right and then I go
this idea is my gift to Tata Greece yes
there I'm telling you they're thinking
they're thinking when you leave at night
these toilets all have adventures you
have no idea what they're doing do you
ever get a celebrity voice because I
could be the voice of a new toilet hello
please have a seat on me I'm American TV
comedian Conan O'Brien oh you had a
pretty big dinner
well thank God we're done see you next
time
and check me out on TBS weeknights at
11:00 do you have toilets you play music
did you think that's necessary to cover
the I don't mean to be repetitive but I
just want a toilet bowl that is low to
the ground and washes the anus I'm just
strongly suspect you're being paid by
the anus counsel you have said the word
600 times heinous heinous heinous llenan
anus janus janus janus janus uranus anus
janus dreams my aim is raining screeners
your anus janus is inexperience their
anus the anus famous ones anus famous
the anus sianis dried the anus are the
NCAA missed a game
that's anus ain't how many seconds does
it take to clean your anus how long is
this last midnight we'll just split them
up
oh I have to stop it if that was me my
anus would have been destroyed a long
time ago what's the longest to humans
endured what's the record has anyone
gone four hours straight and my second
question is did he survive then my third
question is why are you letting me ask
these questions also apparently a power
surge recently you know Sokka
a man was blasted off the pole okay
let's call the police
this is over this is ridiculous do you
like to maybe come get a drink with us
let's get out of here yeah let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
you